Law and Order has gotten consistently
more and more woke as the culture has
gotten more and more woke there's a
scene that's gone viral of a woman being
interviewed by cops but Natalie Jay
Watson raped you do you think I
forgot how could I this entire trial has
been an exercise in reminding me and
this is your chance to do something
about it I am going to believe me
because I can I can afford therapy I
have that luxury and maybe be one
day I'll be
okay but if that
teenager goes to
prison he may not
be
ever I don't want
that Natalie everyone's making fun of
this clip I don't know why they're
making fun of this clip that seems very
accurate to me